[Applause]
welcome everyone to streaming the galaxy
my name is rocket riley and today we're
going to be going over all the details
that have been released about marvel
studios eternals and the film's
potential secret villain but before we
get started if you're new to the channel
please hit the subscribe button and
click the bell icon to be notified when
we upload a new video
also spoiler warning as there may be
talks about the other mcu films and
theories about the upcoming eternals
movie
now eternals is a new film by marvel
studios which will continue the marvel
cinematic universe following the release
of shang chi and the legend of the ten
rings
with an upcoming release date of
november 5th the movie will focus on an
exciting team of new superheroes called
the eternals who have been living on
earth in secret for thousands of years
following the events of avengers endgame
and the sudden reappearance of life in
the universe they're forced out of the
shadows to reunite against the deviants
and potentially another secret villain
after the latest trailer was released it
was just about confirmed that the film's
main villain will be crowe who was born
to the race of deviants
the deviants are an evolutionary
offshoot of humanity created by the
celestials but cursed with an unstable
genetic code
crow however has been able to live out a
prolonged existence alongside the near
immortal eternals this deviant is over
twenty thousand years old and over the
course of his long existence has taken
many forms
in the comics he's known as a military
leader and warlord often involved in
attacks against humanity and the
eternals
crowe tends to do these attacks under
alternate identities using his unique
shape-shifting abilities
although crow will likely be the main
antagonist of the film certain
information has been revealed which
leads us to believe that there will be a
secret villain throughout the movie
druid
played by barry keon druid is one of the
members of the eternals who doesn't
entirely fit in with the team over the
years druid has secluded himself from
the other eternals as he doesn't agree
with how the eternals have interacted
with mankind over the centuries
he believes that the eternals and
potentially the deviants are superior to
humans and that they should treat them
as such
druid's list of powers are pretty
intense near immortality super strength
telepathy illusions telekinesis flight
energy projection teleportation and mind
control
in the most recent trailer it seems as
if drug is using his mind control
abilities on the people who surround
them with their eyes glowing wielding
shotguns towards intruders who could
potentially be the other eternals
at certain times in the comics it's hard
to tell whether druid is a hero or a
villain at one point even working for
the kgb
he's always sought out additional power
using mankind to his own advantage
many times however he's stopped by his
cousin icarus one of the leaders of the
eternals
i think it's likely that druid will work
in a similar capacity to that of loki in
the thor films i believe he'll either be
working with crow to thwart the
eternal's efforts to stop him or simply
against the eternals because of their
differing ideals
he may also persuade crow to align with
him and then turn on him and use crow's
attack as a way to show his superiority
over the other eternals
since this is somewhat similar to loki's
actions in previous mcu films i think
this is pretty likely to happen
at one point in the comics druid even
worked together with thanos in his
attack on the eternal location of
polaria just as loki did in the attack
on new york
in the paleria attack however droog
fooled the other eternals by having
thanos attack druid as well
following the battle drug was able to
take control of paleria as suspicions of
his alliance with thanos were gone
because of events like this and druid's
dark history in the comics it's only a
matter of time until we see the full
weight of his abilities to manipulate
others and potentially turn on the good
guys just as loki did
well that's everything we know so far
about druid and the threat of a secret
villain in the upcoming eternals film if
you enjoyed today's video please
consider hitting the like button and be
sure to subscribe so you don't miss all
of our great content also if you have
ideas that you'd like to share for
future videos please drop them in the
comments section below
from everyone here at streaming the
galaxy we hope you have a great day and
thanks for watching
you